at the biggest mistake that they will
try to make that they will make is that
they will to try to adapt to whatever is
trendy and and so they'll look at the
hits they'll look at last summer
successes or even the independent films
that you know and I'm sure that after a
film like boys don't cry got out
Hollywood was inundated with interesting
little small stories of small town
characters in in some kind of brutal
sexual relationships or whatever on the
other hand avatar of courses films like
that spin loose imitators and so they
will they will they will be more
concerned about selling then they will
be about creating and the attitude of
often of young writers or want to be
writers for the screen is that is that
there's so much on the screen
surely my is better than their
and so and so they want to get made they
want success they want to be in that the
movie business and so they will imitate
whatever they see assuming that because
it awful stories like transformers get
made that that they just have to find
another toy at Toys RS and imitate that
and build a movie around it
well there are degrees of goodness and
badness and so it could be a very subtle
difference but and that one then you
wouldn't know you just would but usually
yeah you can tell pretty well even if
they've written 20 screenplays that
doesn't mean that they have mastered for
example the craft of exposition I can
pick a screenplay up or novel whatever
within a few pages recognize whether or
not this writer has as a degree of craft
the mastery of craft to a certain degree
at least simply by noting how they
handle exposition if they handle
exposition beautifully generally means
this is somebody who's really even
though they haven't been made or
produced or whatever this is somebody
who has thought deeply about the craft
and knows how to draw the reader into
their story and not tell them and burden
them with exposition too soon and too
heavy-handed Lee but draws it with
curiosity and empathy into the story and
in directly invisibly as it were we're
gathering in the exposition that we know
but we're not conscious of it that that
technique alone requires years of
practice and trial and error I can
generally I can tell by the way in which
the writer describes what kind of
imagination the writer has at least
visual imagination I can tell within the
first dialog scene of whether or not
this writer even in an action piece has
any sense of subtext or do they write
their dialogue on the nose I mean there
are certain you know when people perform
in the Olympics
and you have judges sitting there you
know giving them five six seven up to
ten and so forth what are they looking
for they have ways of judging a
performance okay
there's a you know some of it is is is
just sensory you know it there's a
there's a quality of relaxation in the
work there's a quality of confidence in
the work there's a quality of of
centeredness in the work and so some of
these things are sort of being affable
but you can judge a performance of
figure-skating
based upon these plus you know did the
blade land at a certain angle okay that
would get that okay and so it's the same
thing
visit writing is a performance just like
figure skating and I can I can read it
and and have a sense again of confidence
of control a precision of one thing or
another now it doesn't necessarily mean
that by the end of the work I'm going to
be wild but I can tell from the
beginning of the work whether or not the
writer has mastered their craft to a
certain degree but that is one thing but
there's lots of people with superb
craftsmanship and nothing to say
Steven Spielberg brilliant craftsmanship
and nothing to say M night sugar mine
whatever isn't even can really light a
scene and really shoot right and you've
got a cartoon mind comic book mind
you've got nothing to say and so on so
the mastery of craft is no guarantee
overall on the other hand you may see
people are still struggling with the
crap but they have passion they have
insight and they really understand human
behavior in relationships or whatever
and or they have some wonderful
imaginative ideas about you know
alternate worlds in whatever is your
onre
and so I'm noting the quality of the the
craft is no guarantee of excellence but
it's an interesting thing that that that
a lack of craftsmanship and a lack of
insight into life seem to go hand in
hand it's no accident
the bad writers also have nothing to say
okay having something to say seems to
inspire people all right but but not
necessarily so that it's it's not an
it's not an easy thing necessarily and
he can make mistakes and you can judge
books erroneously by covers but there
are touch stones that you can use along
the way that give you a sense of quality
versus banality